majority of adults say stress connected
with the coronavirus has had a negative
effect on their mental health and the
experts say some children are suffering
the same effects navigating the new
normal parents Edition is a new special
vibe by the Viacom CBS learning service
noggin it offers tips for parents
worried about their kids mental
well-being my son found crying in the
pantry the other day and I I while I
needed to release I felt bad because I
felt like oh no is he gonna feel like I
can't handle this situation number one
that this does give us a chance to model
for our kids what it's like really
really sad when we're feeling really
overwhelmed The Specials lead expert is
California Surgeon General that's dr.
Nadine Burke Harris she joins us she's a
pediatrician so she knows about working
with kids good to see you dr. Burke
Harris that was Jamie Ziegler by the way
from The Sopranos who said my son saw me
the other day crying and I want to start
with that because I think a lot of
parents are wondering is it harmful for
your children to see that you're showing
stress or anxiety is that okay well I
think that what kids really need to see
is that we have these feelings we have
these emotions and then what do we do
about them it's not that they can never
see us experiencing stress or anxiety
but this is an opportunity for us to
model for them Wow
you know I'm feeling really frustrated
and upset right now and here's what I do
for myself right and that's the really
important thing yeah what are the mental
health concerns you have for children
right now because listen they're taking
their cues from their parents but they
must be feeling some stuff too certainly
we see that you know a lot of kids are
feeling a lot of uncertainty a lot of
anxiety and it's really important for
people to know that it's not just in
their heads right for both for kids and
adults the experience that we're having
is pretty stressful and when we talk
about stress really it's the
body making stress hormones and these
stress hormones can do things like
affect our sleep affect our mood affect
our judgment for kids it can affect the
way that they learn and it can even
affect our health right for example high
levels of stress hormones can make us
more susceptible to infection for
example by affecting the way our immune
system functions so helping kids
understand what they can do to help to
you know be healthy and you know reduce
those stress hormones I think is really
important we flesh it on the screen
briefly their doctor but what are some
of the signs that parents should look
out for that say to them oh my child is
having a problem here struggling a bit
well it depends on the age of the child
but for little or ones some of the
things that we see are developmental
regression right so for example if a
child was previously potty-trained and
then they go back to wedding or they had
been sleeping through the night and then
they go back to to getting up for
school-aged children you might see
increased likelihood of you know
difficulty focusing or paying attention
or headaches or tummy ache so sometimes
school-aged children really feel it in
their bodies and for for teenagers
teenagers can be tough to flush out
anyways right but they could become more
withdrawn or they can become more
aggressive or angry right and then it's
really important to to reach out and
check check in you specialize in the
connection between mental stress and
physical health what are you focusing on
why is that important yes so what we see
is that there's a large body of research
that shows that when we experience
significant stress or adversity
particularly in this developmentally
critical period of childhood that it
kind of
things like brain development the immune
system hormonal systems and even the way
our DNA is read and transcribed so where
science is now understanding that our
environments and especially in childhood
have a significant effect on our health
not only during childhood but also
throughout life and what that means is
that we can put that science into
practice to make sure that kids are
having safe stable and nurturing
relationships and environments alright
dr. Nadine Burke Harris I knew you
worked with kids when I heard your mic
check and you went green eggs and ham
instead of ABCD or one two three four
five
thank you very good to see you this
morning thank you so much you can hear
more from dr. Burke Harris and noggins
navigating the new normal special just
go to the CBS this morning Facebook page
for more information on that